[Musique]
maître dupond-moretti
c'est moi qui vous ai contacteur
pourquoi l affaire viguier je vais vous
proposer de reprendre la faire si je
prends mes repères je commence par dire
le bossu je vous parle d'une erreur
judiciaire a suivi gay vous avez mis
trois jours à déclarer la disparition de
l'autre phare en vrai ça peut même pas
s'il est mort d'un si ça se trouve elle
est partie il n'y a pas de calavi a pas
de mobile
nous étions chez une amie de la famille
dit qu'ils aucune preuve montrent en
outre qu'une taille sur pourquoi est-il
débarrasser du matelas sur lequel
dormait son épouse de 150 heures des
coups de téléphone où on va dire je suis
emmerdé les personnes qui connaissent le
fier que mon sac à main dans la maison
avec les clés de la maison
on est à peu près sûr qu'à préméditation
s'il voulait divorcer
jacques ne l'a pas supporté on s'appuie
sur des témoignages et tout amène à
monsieur viguier à la piste conjugales
dans la baignoire vous voyez du sang
c'est vrai ma dame qu'il y à de
nouvelles écoutes téléphoniques au
dossier ah bon vous en pensez quoi vous
les persuader les culpabiliser iggy n'en
démord pas je fais en sorte que les
rumeurs qui courent ça j'ai pas le droit
de faire quoi
[Musique]
pas de moi
alors vous m'avez menti je peux vous
faire confiance si je vous l'avais dit
vous mariez pas confier les écoutes
faites moi confiance une dernière fois
je
[Musique]